what i had uh
promised to do here was to deliver uh
what i
am going to argue is a compelling
logical proof
that anti-racism the framework offered
by ibram kennedy in
several of his books is
false i'm going to argue that the
implication of the obviousness of its
falseness is that it is in fact
sophistry
and that its purpose is to drive us all
into behaving as
ibrahim kendy would have us behave
thereby it's a kind of manipulation so
what is the proof
well the proof involves a phenomenon
that i think many of us are aware of
with respect to dogs so the central
claim of anti-racism is that there is no
such thing as not racist that everything
is either racist by virtue of its action
in a system that is racist
or anti-racist by virtue of its opposing
that phenomenon and that there's no
place that we could hope to stand so in
effect we can extrapolate this to
there's no
um colorblind society that in fact
society must be color aware because
there's no
not racist way for society to be
structured
so what's the proof the proof is this
have you ever met a racist dog
yes yeah me too um racist dogs are a
phenomenon
and i'm going to hypothesize why racist
dogs exist
nothing i'm going to say depends on this
hypothesis being correct
some number of people may be screaming
right now what do you mean a racist dog
never met a racist dog what are you
talking about well a racist dog
is a dog that responds with uh
aggression and maybe fear differentially
based on the race of the people it
encounters and
you know yeah not not against different
colors of dogs but about
right against different colors of people
exactly that other thing may or may not
exist too
but um but let's just say that uh
certainly
uh growing up it was commonly discussed
that some people's dogs
had problems with people from certain
races right they might respond
badly to black people or latinos
and what i understand what i imagine
that this reflects
is that people have fears or
stereotypical responses differentially
based on race
we know that they do that is arguably
racism but it is at least in that same
neighborhood
and because dogs are very tightly
tuned in to their owners needs and
desires and all of this the dogs pick up
the uh racism or its antecedent that
exists in their owners and then
uh embarrass their owners by reacting uh
to people who have done nothing other
than
have a particular phenotypic marker um
so
all right racist dogs exist right by
some mechanism maybe that one
here's the question though a lot of dogs
don't do this
our dog doesn't do this right right um
are those dogs anti-racist no
my claim is there may be anti-racist
dogs you could at least in principle as
proof of concept you could create an
anti-racist dog if you could train
it to recognize bankers
in the act of redlining or something
like that a dog could
bark in some way right so in principle
there could be an anti-racist dog but
what they're most definitely are so
the definition of anti-racist here then
is uh
working to reduce historical
uh oppression by making the situation
in the moment unequal so as to end up
with equity
is that this is the working definition
of anti-racism okay in principle and i'm
not that's obviously a ridiculous
example i've come up with but the point
is
the redlining bankers right the
redlining bankers is going to be tough
to train a dog to spot that but you know
it could happen and so it were you to do
that you would have an anti-racist dog
so let's
you know give candy his due an
anti-racist dog is conceivable
but what we have is a lot of dogs who
don't respond differentially based on
the race of anybody they're not paying
attention to that characteristic and
what that
establishes is that a framework in which
we define
not racist out of existence is
inherently
false not racist is a category that can
exist
in a context where racism does exist
also and so my point to you
dr kennedy is your framework is bad
we can demonstrate that using a familiar
example
from dogs there are not racist dogs even
though
they could be racist and in principle
could be anti-racist
and therefore it is upon you
you can either point out what is
incorrect about
this proof you can ignore it which is
what i expect you to do
thereby suggesting that maybe there's
something to this proof
or you can
[Music]
what would i say one was was that uh
challenge it
you can accept it you can challenge it
which i would love for you to do
um or you can ignore it which is what i
expect
but for the rest of us i suspect
that one form of pushback will be
in the form that we have become
unfortunately all too familiar with
in evolutionary biology which is that's
not people it's not relevant
right but see that's the glory of this
proof is that
um if the idea is this argument
is logically sound that is to say
kendy's argument is logically sound but
only resident to human then okay let's
hear the argument about why that
is and you know if i had you know if i
had
argued that there are not racist
typewriters you could accuse me of
uh dragging us into a realm you know
that was uh irrelevant you could accuse
me of sophistry but my point is because
racist dogs are a real phenomenon it is
a proper analogy
right racist dogs let's put it this way
racist dogs
are a phenomenon anti-racist dogs are
plausible and not racist dogs are common
and my point is going to be amongst
humans
racists exist anti-racists exist
and not racists exist and he is defining
them out of existence and
he's defining the third category not
racist out of existence which
frankly uh in modern times is i believe
most of us right and it is the very
definition of sophistry
right the point is it's a hard argument
to field which doesn't make it
true right in other words the counter
argument is difficult
to articulate but that doesn't make it
right and my point is that actually this
matters it's not just
some guy deployed a bad argument it's
that that argument
actually has a moral imperative that it
drags along with it which is it is your
obligation
to do what i ibraham candy say because
of course you want to be anti-racist
because what are your other options
racist right right so the point is that
is that is manipulative sophistry
and it needs to end we need to recognize
not racist is not only a real category
but in fact i would argue it is the only
long-term basis on which society can
properly function
right right we have to shoot for a
colorblind society
and defining it as not a possibility and
therefore
to the extent that you are not willing
to sign up for some formulation you're a
racist
that's nonsense and it was martin luther
king's dream
of course yeah because he was a wise man
yeah um
so i guess just a just a little aside
relevant to that before we move into
talking about vaccinations a bit
um i think i think the widespread
embrace
of candy's formulation of anti-racism
and
roman deangelo's formulation of white
fragility
demonstrates that the left of which we
are a part have become a deeply gullible
people
um and it's gullibility is a feature of
being a follower
right of being um and and it makes you
pray to authoritarians
of course and once you are prayed to
authoritarians you are probably more
likely to accept authoritarianism when
it shows up on your doorstep because it
sort of feels like it's what you're
doing anyway and isn't it working well
for me why not for everyone dick dots
are
easier to swallow if you're gullible to
begin with so things like
only white people can be racist and all
of them are or
believe all women all the time under all
circumstances
or trust the science right these are
these are insanities
like these may these there's no way that
anyone should be able to say any of
those little
little uh sound bites with a straight
face and mean it without irony and yet
we have a lot a lot of people who and
you know and now policy a lot of policy
being made
on the basis um that these that these
truisms
um which um which point
actually to a um
not a dumb populist but a gullible
populace
ours are spreading and you know i'm not
saying there's not increasingly plenty
of dimwittery to go around too but i
think it's the gullibility
um that is um that is really getting to
me this week
right um so in that in light of that
um before we go on i just want to say
that that is my hope
in delivering what is in essence uh
a three-line proof is that it is so
succinct
that those who don't know what to say
there is no
not racism there's only racism and
anti-racism which side are you
on has the thing right it's it's
sufficiently small yeah that you could
put it on a card
and the point is actually i know that's
not true and before you tell me the next
thing
right that i have to do in order not to
be over with the racists
i'm going to tell you that that
formulation is nonsense that's my hope
is that increasingly
we will be able to take the things about
which people
are bullied into acceptance the
gullibility that you're pointing to
and provide um a very
a very simple method for diffusing
that uh that trap well i feel like um i
don't i don't yet
see it in its totally simple form um
you know in terms of the the three line
proof the sound bytes etc but
you know having a stack of these cards
like actually you know this is something
that that could be
valuable to people that you know having
a stack of cards it's like
you know racist short definition
anti-racist short definition
not racist short definition this is in
the the field of possibilities like this
is in the solution set
option three is it i'm taking door
number three here you go you're telling
me
if i'm not an anti-racist i'm a racist
no take this
are we done like like that's the
argument right there and
a lot of people find themselves utterly
hamstrung
when faced with this garbage right and
and you know so to some degree
what you've proposed and what we're
doing sort of thinking out loud and
talking it through
is is serving i think one of the things
that we think it's doing and that we're
hearing from people that it's doing is
helping
to um give people the language that they
can use when confronted with a situation
but also having something very short and
that then can be handed to someone else
so that they can have it come back to be
like
oh oh not racist right
right so um i think that this is an
important
thing that we should all be doing we
should all be generating these succinct
uh responses and i think actually we've
done it before
because you know be hard-pressed to
figure out
whether we were actually first on this
but
we on one of our live streams
responded to the claim that the protests
this summer
were mostly peaceful by
pointing out that uh you know that
so was the kennedy assassination and
world war ii mostly peaceful if you're
going to you know count the number of
things
it was mostly useful right which then
caught on and so the point is
mostly peaceful um died a spectacular
death as a claim because so many people
realized actually that doesn't mean a
goddamn thing does it
right mostly peaceful is is is sophistry
it's it's
rare events tend to define eras and they
tend to find movements that like
rare events are the things that start
and stop uh big moments
right so we should you know generate
these things and in this case
um you know uh dogs are like people
they can be racist that said most of
them are not
why is that not true of people good
doctor candy
yes good
you